قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطونيو لا
يمكننا تقديم الدعم العسكري الاوكرانيا هو
قرار سيادي لكل بلد واضاف بلانكين خلال
مؤتمر الناس صحفي مع نظيره البريطاني جيمس
كليفر لي ان الهدف من تزويدي اوكرانيا
بالسلاح والوصول الى وضع يسهل على طرفين
الانخراطه في المفاوضات
الروسي فان دعمنا لاوكانيا
حتى قبل بدء الغزو الروسي وعندما شنت
روسيا الحرب كان لدى اوكرانيا ما يموتنهام
لتكون اوكرانيا قادره على الصمود وان
يكونوا مستعدين لاستخدام انظمه الاسلحه
التي نزودهم بها قدمنا 25 مليار دولار من
الدعم العسكري في اقل من عام وهناك حزم من
المساعدات العسكريه الاخرى نحن مصممنا على
ان يكون لدى اوكرانيا ما تحتاجه للدفاع عن
نفسها في المعركه لكي يصل الوضع الى ما
يسهل قراءه الطرفين في المفاوضات
بدوره قال وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه جيمس
كليفر لنحزمتها مساعدته بلاده الجديده
لاوكرانيا ست تشمل المدفعيه الثقيله
واسلحه مزوده باجهزه الرؤيه الليليه كليفر
لي كذا وجود التزام طويل الامد من قبل
واشنطن لمواصله تزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه
في المملكه المتحده
عسكريا واقتصادي لاوكرانيا من السهل
التركيز على تقديمي بعض المعدات المتخصصه
لكن بالطبع الدبابات هي العنوان والابراج
اليوم حزمه مساعداتنا ستشمل المدفعيه
الثقيله واجهزه الرؤيه الليليه اضافه الى
الاسلحه الخفيفه والذخيره المتنوعه